[Music]  Lionel Richie is speaking out about his  daughter Sofia's relationship with Scott  Disick it's a big deal in a recent  interview with The Daily Telegraph the  68 year old singer opened up about his  19 year old daughters romance with a 34  year old reality star calling it quote  just a phase but says Scott's a very  nice guy the music icon shared similar  sentiments about the couple's budding  romance with et in November 2017 all you  have to do is understand phases don't  get involved make you comment keep a  straight face don't get involved and  sure enough it's always the person you  want to be with your daughter or your  son they don't pick those burgers as  always the person they fall in love with  and you go be calm just be calm Scott  and Sofia made their first public  appearance together as a couple in  December but have been linked since May  2017  Cheers are you dating whatever side  [Music]  you